named Eric Hayes here though wearing
possibly the most dabble of stuff
anyone's ever had diablo max matarazzo
and i believe it sir that you have been
playing this game since 9:00 p.m.
yesterday
yep I've been playing till about 5 or 6
a.m. and then I was like I got to be on
the lobby so let's get two hours of
sleep you're asleep yep and then you
know scoot on over here help set up and
and I also believe that you were caught
you're coming to show off the game here
and then you're going home and you've
taken the rest of the week off to play
reap results yeah it's a thing all right
three days off so it's fair to say that
you're you're a fan of the game let's
let's hop straight in here and if anyone
has any questions please put them in the
trash in twitch on GameSpot or a tweet
us at GameSpot and I know there's gonna
be a bunch of questions and so let's
just hop straight into it and Erte
there's a bunch of stuff in this
expansion pack for Diablo 3 please in no
specific order tell us what the hell is
in this game ok so there's obviously a
new Act mm-hmm so I'm gonna jump in Act
five right now so you guys can see some
of that environment and atmosphere it's
West March and then on top of that there
is a new class the crusader ok somewhere
between like a warrior and a priest I
hear sort of yeah so it's kind of like
similar to the Paladin a little bit they
kind of wanted to make something similar
lore wise it's like they were doing
something while the paladin's were doing
something in Diablo 2 so now you get to
meet the Crusaders and yeah you're super
on point with the Diablo Lord you know
it's about the game look this monk is
dropping bells on people let's not worry
too much about the law right now okay
but yeah so on top of that you know
there's there's obviously new adventure
mode as well that you can unlock once
you beat mouth eel which is the new boss
in Act five so that's one of the biggest
pose of this the adventure mode of
hearing yep
that is probably the biggest thing it's
it's kind of their new end game and on
top of just the bounties there's
Nephilim rifts as well
which you can open once you do the
bounties which I'll show you guys after
I play some more guys because that's
what we do in Diablo you just do a lot
of guys and a lot of guys and get loot
and because of the patch that when live
just before Reaper fold you're getting
way better loot yep that's right
I'll show showcase some of that stuff to
you guys and also on top of that now in
Reaper of souls there's also a new
merchant that she after you save her
during the quest in a knack excuse me
nack five year she actually will help
you modify some of that gear to make it
even more suitable for your character
alright so I'll show you guys that too
in a little bit like helping complement
the skills that you particularly have
yeah so like sometimes like a lot of
people that were playing Diablo 3
originally were like oh man if only this
weapon had a socket or yes if only this
weapon had dexterity instead of strength
well now you have a means to kind of
change the gear you find so that you can
cater it to your character I'm over
burning because yeah I'm because you got
so much juice as how much of this as
somebody who I played Diablo 3 when I
first came out I wasn't a massive player
of the previous games but I did enjoy it
but it seems like the past year has been
like a long narrative of people and
complaining about what Diablo 3 was how
much of a reaction to those specific
demands from the fanbase do you think
Reaper of souls is there I mean it's
there definitely going in the right
direction they're listening to the
community you know a lot of it I think a
lot of the sourness came from the
auction house which is also being closed
yeah and so they're kind of returning
form kind of so to speak is it more like
Diablo to them than it was when it came
out of the box yeah definitely uh and on
top of that I believe yesterday they
dropped news that in a couple of months
they're going to also have ladders which
is a huge thing in Diablo 2 yeah I
explained the ladders thing cuz I that I
heard yourself and Kirk and a bunch of
people freaking out the ladders were
coming to Diablo 3 what was that it's
like some sort of persistent leaderboard
system or yeah so basically what happens
is when when there's a ladder reset or
one
new season starts you have the option to
you know either play you know your
character that goes into like a like a
default League or something like that
default ladder but then the new ladder
basically gives you the ability to start
fresh with everyone else and it's
basically kind of like this competition
or this race to see who can get to like
the max level the fastest yeah and then
also like by virtue of that everyone you
know starts since everyone is starting
at zero like it's it's cool to compete
for gear and then there's also a lot of
specific gear so like there's special
special gear that you can only get via
ladder and I may be wrong but it sounds
like a lot of what's what's in Reaper
souls maybe Chris you can kind of like
agree with me on this maybe or not but a
lot of this stuff seems to be for people
who play to have a lot of Diablo or at
least like you know the series Chris did
you play much Diablo for played about I
played through the first act of the
hablo three and I think that it's
there's kind of a balance right because
the the patch we mentioned earlier you
know that makes the base experience in
the base loop these gathering like much
more rich and rewarding for any player
and so I think that like the base casual
like just come in and play a few rounds
or a few levels player is gonna be
rewarded that way but then you're you've
got this whole like later game and end
games like richness that they're putting
in with the ladders with the adventure
mode forgive me if I setting that stuff
incorrectly that makes sense Diablo
nomenclature ain't quite on point but it
seems like they're sort of expanding it
from both in both ways I mean definitely
just even talking with you know a bunch
of our colleagues here in the office
after that patch had dropped a lot of a
lot of people have come back and started
to play and you know there's been a huge
response to you know just all the all
the gear that's been dropping and kind
of like I said it before like kind of a
return to form it's almost like it's
like second I launched at this time
stage like people are talking about
Diablo and in Radium
I don't know yeah like they're pretty
hyped up about it we got a bunch of
questions coming in here at Pizza the
great asks on twitch did they fix the
character builds or does everyone turn
into the same thing like before okay so
that is by virtue of the
that you get now yeah it definitely has
changed how you build your characters
I'll further elaborate a little bit but
there are more items that you know drop
elemental damage now and you know like
I'm doing fire damage here right yeah so
there's actually here that caters to
that fire damage and that changes your
spec so there's not gonna be so much
like Oh everyone's kind of running the
loop like one or two cookie cutter specs
that everyone's running it kind of
allows the player to choose a little bit
depending on what gear they get to drop
does it kind of diversify the skill sets
you know I can't complete you're gonna
leave that socket even Kerry key on of
death just yeah in there yeah well
that's what happens when you play for
that long I guess it kind of just let
things go
also because like I said my stash is
pretty full you are over encumbered
young man pretty good to earn a spot in
your stash monkey robot on GameSpot asks
is it known that Blizzard is bringing
this title to Xbox one ps4 but did they
also intends to release this as DLC for
the ps3 or 360 versions how much you
know about this coming of the consoles
so I know for sure I'm just gonna change
the mode real quick but I know for sure
that it's coming to ps4 because I played
it yeah at Blizzcon it's it's
interesting because Blizzard treats
console and PC slightly different and it
was another interesting realization for
me here in the office it's like
Giancarlo loves console version yeah Bob
Jones from the chat
he loves console version and so like
once yeah once uh once that comes out
which I they haven't done a release date
for it um you know that since I have
played it and I think it's probably
gonna be like at e3 I think maybe PAX
East - it's gotta be coming soon I also
hear there's like stuff in this where
you couldn't unlock like special cards
for hearthstone like special Dexter's
stuff yeah so there's like this or
they're just gonna keep like just
fishing this in for like all this extra
content I know it just when you thought
you were out yeah they're definitely
synergizing across the board so here's
the new merchant she allows you to do
something fun called transmogrification
which is something that again
transmogrify take fast
Ken's Naga
there you go alright alright but it's
kind of like the Lao thing where you can
change your weapon or or armor to
something else yeah aesthetically look
cooler or weirder whatever you want to
decide to do but Calvin and Hobbes used
to do inside cardboard box see ya
she also lets you change like a stat on
an item so like I said earlier you know
there's a lot of complaints of like oh
if only I had this or I really wish it
had that like especially before the the
patch where a loot was like good loot
was so hard to come exactly so like
these pants or something right like I
don't care about this increased way of
100 fists I can I can see what it can
reroll you to and as long as I have
aerials to change or I mean to craft it
I can get anything from here so I'll
just try it just for funsies do it it'll
ask you because once you do it on this
one property it you can only change this
one property into those proper-- okay oh
so it's just gonna choose one of those
seven different things you can't select
which one no you get a it randomly rolls
too so it's like oh I got crippling wave
or fists of thunder it's like I use
crippling wave sweet okay so I picked
that instead I actually do use crippling
wave see yeah crippling wave sounds like
the worst like it's just crippling a
bunch of people just a big wave of
crippling getting uploaded sortation
Danny yeah it's a horrible horrible
world and speaking of Bob Jones 1980 Bob
Jones 1980 asks has Eric already beaten
death I have I slain him last night
yesterday is now immortal as are all of
us the slaying of death and it's gonna
put a massive strain on earth's
resources but we thank you for for your
endeavors of course we [ __ ] it so this
is this is kind of the big big deal here
this is adventure mode okay it actually
allows you to freely move from act 2 act
which is something you couldn't do
before so here's act 1
here's act - here's act 3 at 4 at 5 etc
previously you could only be in like one
act and then like you're like okay I
played through that I either go back and
farm like this one area or I got to go
out and choose another and you couldn't
go back to when you come from little
could you not without exiting the game
right yeah so oh this one's actually
long let me show you a shorter one but
so what what the sort of idea behind
this is that you can
it's almost kind of what it sounds like
to me is it kind of sounds like wow is
in that you you go to different areas
get different quests perform them and
then it does the endgame happen the same
way like do you eventually just have to
level off the department you can fight
Diablo I mean like fighting Diablo is
just part of the game I think their
endgame here is something you do after
the bounty so you do bounties like you
said they're kind of like quests or
objective based like we can see there it
says enter the hell rip level 2 and kill
all that enemies so it's kind of like
you do that and then you get rewarded
and then after you do a certain amount
of bounties you're gonna get these rift
shards which then allows you to access
their current endgame which is randomly
done rent a randomly generated dungeons
what would I call it again something
real dumb at Netflix and therefore lived
with that probably exactly how do you
know what's it'd be like having this
massive amount of like dictionary like
vocabulary that is completely useless
outside of referred to this video game I
don't know Danny let's talk about soccer
all right nicely done shots fired yeah
alright that was offside Chris waters I
don't get it speak English wait no how
long can you see yourself playing this I
know you're taking the rest of the week
off oh you are you happy about that
somebody you like enjoys the series
clearly you've got a mass amount of the
t-shirt it's not just for show as
somebody who likes them this much what
do you think about this I'm what do you
think were you were you pissed about the
AH blow through when it came out so I
personally wasn't pissed about Diablo 3
when it came out I actually had a lot of
fun now granted I was a huge fan of
Diablo 2 so understand all the anger
yeah that comes with it but you know
that it's it's all about value
proposition and it's not fair to kind of
Judge Diablo 3 based solely on Diablo 2
and be like oh it's got to like live up
to this exact same thing do you think it
was too high a watermark or something I
think so I think they everyone just kind
of had something in their mind and of
course it was like 10 years right it was
like a long time until it came out so
it's like oh it has to live up to this
or it's no good but most Triple A games
nowadays it's like you pay 60 bucks and
you're probably getting maybe 10 20
hours out of the game like Diablo if you
got 30 40 hours out of the game I think
you got your money's worth
granted it's not exactly what you
thought it would be but I got high
personal II got more than that but you
know there were a lot of people that
didn't play it as long as I did so how
much this Reaper soldier it's $40 and do
you think that this kind of brings it up
to the level that Diablo should have
been like are you okay with spending 40
bucks I'm getting this experience which
is perhaps closer to what you would have
wanted it at the hablo 3 yes definitely
I think this is more worth it than the
original Diablo 3 just because of like
the fact that they fix so many things
it's a lot better there's a better end
game where it's not like you're you're
constantly in this same area farming the
same stuff and you're hoping like oh I
hope this drops so after you do a bounty
you get one of these rift key stone
fragments you do five of them you got 35
of those but so I've been farming awhile
so after you get five v25 in one one
area you get this horrid cache which
material gives to you and it drops like
a bunch of stuff oh oh that's sweet swag
so like hopefully you get a legendary
which I have in but you also get key
stone fragments from that so let me show
you guys the endgame real quick I'm just
gonna leave that stuff there not the
feather Yeti oh I know sorry so this is
the this is their endgame you turn in
these shards you turn in five of them
and opens the randomly generated dungeon
okay so you could be in anywhere like
act one two three four five like an area
yeah but it can have monsters of because
I only act because all the dungeons in
all the acts were all randomly generated
anyway right yeah you would all yeah but
you would fight the same specific
monsters yeah whereas here like I mean
well this is not the best example but
like I am in Act one area and these
would be act 1 monsters but we could
potentially see you know act 5 monsters
here and they're like what is in
actually act 1 we have area so I want
the benefit to this is it loot dropping
as well yeah so basically there's this
bar here that you fill up and then that
bar fills up as you kill monsters there
are a lot of elite packs in here which
are those blue champion packs and you
have like a higher chance to give you
better loot
and then at the end of the nephilim riff
it spawns like like a rift guardian
which is like the boss for this specific
rift that you open cool and he drops you
a bunch of blood shards as well as like
the chance to get Legendary's and other
things it just depends on if you're
lucky or not and then the rift shards
which is another form of currency
outside of gold allows you to gamble in
town with a certain vendor and it gives
you a small chance of getting legendary
so there's like multiple ways like
layers together there are there are
layers upon layers upon layers it all
boils down to kill monsters and get loot
yeah and in just a bunch of different
ways
pretty much different pipelines for you
know different rewards for killing
monsters that lead to different
pipelines for getting loot but the start
is always kill monsters and the end of
those get loot Erte we are gonna let you
go home and kill monsters and get Luth
for the rest of your week thank you so
much for coming in and showing us Avery
I'm gonna hydrate eat properly yes you
know get to get a little bit of rest
it's your fire and we want to see you
back next week
no no that's not a drink